and now we're gonna do the cool story
yeah this is cool I want to hear about
this so this next story near-death
experience London man shares what it's
like to die and then come back real life
Jon Snow this was just a couple days ago
yeah real life Jess no I read a book
about this a long time ago mm-hmm and
I'm gonna I'm gonna tell you this they
some researchers reached out to a ton of
people who had died yeah and had been
resuscitated and they cut out people
they thought were like their stories
didn't quite make sense in terms of like
they weren't really dead okay a lot of
people would say things like I felt cold
and saw light in front of me and they'd
be like that's the operating table like
that's you in the ER yeah so they look
like that they looked for people who
were in very specific circumstances
maybe they died in the street or that a
heart attack at home and then someone
saved them yeah like this guy's story
let me read you the story and then I'm
gonna tell you some crazy stuff because
when I read this I was like dude this is
exactly what the book was talking about
what what happens when you die
you know and it feels like dude maybe
this is it maybe we have found the
answers I don't know
no one knows because we're alive well I
do know that like when when even plants
when plants die all hey lose mass no no
all all living things release DMT right
into the brain now you're talking like
Joe Rogan well it's it's interesting
though yeah all living things have it in
them plants animals all anything that is
alive has DMT in it and when it dies
releasable gets released crazy like and
I also I haven't done that but what is
it it no it's like it makes you trip I
read I write III heard to and this could
be wrong that you lose a little bit of
mass when you die yeah heard that sorry
yeah and you're and you're a fancy
doctor isn't there isn't there like a
specific amount though yeah they did a
weird thing where they have people die
on like a really fine scale you know
it's really weird and something got goes
but it's always the same amount isn't it
it's like let's read this story cuz
we're gonna burn out we're gonna blow
some minds yeah
Adam tap was 35 years old when he died a
paramedic in London for 15 years tap was
doing some woodworking in his shop on
February 28th 2018 when as he says he
got a little cavalier with a wood
atching device that
ice arced into his hand and electrocuted
him his heart stopped for eleven and a
half minutes quote it was like someone
flipped a switch all of my senses were
overwhelmed by 12,000 volts of DC
electricity it was one of the most
excruciating ly painful things I have
ever experienced
I remember forcing thoughts like I think
I'm being electrocuted
luckily tap had a friend with him who
had recently taken a high-voltage safety
course Mark Wilson disconnected tap and
called for taps wife Stephanie Stephanie
is a cardiac RN and immediately started
CPR they quickly called 9-1-1 this is
why we get these stories because if his
wife wasn't and they didn't really know
what they were doing yeah I don't think
you would've made it yeah for sure I
don't know I'm not a doctor but the fact
that these circumstances add up tells us
exactly why we're getting this story
about what happened when you died well
he does but luckily that provide sums it
up check it out the ambulance showed up
to the ambulance showed up and two of
his fellow paramedics drilled a hole
into his shoulder bone for drug access
Wow they gave him an epinephrine and
defend a gave him an epinephrine and
defibrillated him twice before bringing
him back to the land of the living
tap didn't wake up for six hours and
when he did he was in the ICU intubated
which he says is a strange way to wake
up
I'm sure tap is one of the 158
individuals who participated in a study
between Western University and the
University of leash that used text
mining and artificial intelligence to
find that most people respond positively
to near-death experiences or NDEs
while the sample size is small
researchers feel the text mining
approach will only increase in validity
as more narratives are collected from
survivors of and E's this is probably
similar when I was talking about I was
reading this book this is years ago
participants were asked to write freely
about their near-death experience and
those narratives were analyzed by
researchers at Western University said
dr. Andreas so do an associate professor
in westerns department of physics and
astronomy the idea was to try and
extract information from the text in a
very quantitative way without any bias
using a technique called text mining
traditionally near-death experiences are
explored using standardized
questionnaires like the Grayson scale
which asks participants a series of
questions answered using multiple-choice
the problems
who said is it as a potentially biased
approach that may skew recollections
with text mining we extracted words that
were more on the positive side like
light and wellness and saw that words
like fear while still part of the
narrative were much less dominant than
the positive outcomes after being dead
for more than 11 minutes tap was
resuscitated and fell into a coma for
six hours but while he was essentially
dead to the world he said he had a
profound experience all of a sudden I
just woke up in a place that seemingly
I'd always been it was black and it kind
of seemed like space said tap tap said
that he felt a frequency wash over him
and saw what looked like gasoline on
water with all these geometric shapes
and patterns adding that something was
communicating with him through thoughts
and feelings and emotions I just started
fading into the fabric of the universe
it was so warm and peaceful and pleasant
to the fourth dimension
it appears simple curiosity and a desire
to better understand near-death
experiences were the driving forces
behind the study according to so do both
he and his colleagues the university of
leisure are very much interested in
consciousness and altered states of
consciousness tap eventually welcome
from the coma he asked how long he'd had
been out and said he had he was told it
had been 30 he said if he was told it
had been 30 years he would have believed
it his sense of time was a bit confused
but what was more surprising is that he
didn't feel quite at home in his body it
actually took me a while to feel
comfortable in my body again just
breathing I was so hyper aware of having
to breathe or having to take a breath it
took me a couple of months I just felt
so foreign in my body what a weird
feeling right the experience was
indescribable said tap adding it took
him a while to be able to put in words
quote what I take away from it is this
absolute unequivocal feeling that death
is supposed to happen it might not be
pleasant and we might not want it but it
is supposed to happen and it is very
literally a necessary part of all life
as fearful as these moments are for
people it's not necessarily a bad thing
it's actually deeply beautiful it sounds
like he like went to note the next
immense dimension a higher dimension
yeah or maybe DMT got released in his
brain and he trips yeah and he was alive
I don't know
let me tell you a story I was reading a
book a long time ago I'm not gonna
pretend like it's an academic text I
don't know but this was maybe like man
13 years ago and it was talking about
how they were interviewing people and
asking them to write down about their
experiences very similar to this and
they looked for patterns they tried to
remove stories that didn't quite make
sense like it was very obvious someone
didn't really die there on an operating
table yeah and most of these stories
they found a pattern the pattern was
that for many of these people who died
they described it exactly like he did
they felt warm they were in this space
with strange shapes yeah and they felt
like they were this is what I read in
the book that they felt like they were a
part of some ever like some like it's
it's hard to explain what what I thought
my I was the frequency that when when he
said that I felt a frequency wash over
like an energy wave well I mean we are
all vibrating everything right frequency
all matter is frequency so you know when
you when you step back into a higher
dimension I guess you know it would make
sense that you could see it and feel the
frequencies well so universe look into
that cool yeah I got more but basically
what it said was the pattern was
everybody who died felt like they were a
small energy consciousness it was them
in the space and they were moving
towards a gigantic they were all moving
in the same direction towards a larger
something similar to themselves of like
conscious energy and so the takeaway
from the book was like we don't know
very much it's an interesting pattern
and we can speculate one of the
speculation wasn't one of the bits of
speculation they had was perhaps we are
all tiny fragments of this energy and
then after we die we all join which you
could perceive as like they felt good
they felt happy at peace and they they
longed to be a part of this giant you
know energy mm-hmm so whatever that is
perhaps it was a limited interpretation
of what was really happening because
they were only bringing from there and
yeah they're right or it's not meant to
be comprehended by a human mind right
when you're free from your body you
understand when you come back you're
like I don't feel that were three
dimensional beings but now here's your
cyst in this plane here but have you
ever seen the ever seen that movie what
the bleep do we know yeah great movie so
it's a lot of hokey new
wage stuff for sure I'm all about the
quantum physics man but they do a
segment that kind of explains another
bit of what he's talking about
when they they say imagine a
two-dimensional universe yeah and these
people have no concept of up or down if
you pushed your finger through their
reality they would see just like a
sphere grow and then shrink because it's
the cross-section of your finger right
moving through their dimension so maybe
what he was seeing was he s he came out
of our dimension like actual physical
dimension mm-hmm into the next dimension
was looking down at three dimensional
reality three dimensional reality right
from a higher plane of existence that's
so cool I don't know man I mean I don't
know because I you know I haven't died
yet yeah but one day I'm gonna die and
I'm gonna I'm gonna see it for myself
and I that type of person I and I just
see it you know I think he's right
though that we're supposed to die yeah
it makes sense but it's the circle of
life but it's not just about the circle
of life it's like whatever the function
of life is you know evolution or
whatever yeah if we didn't die life
would like biologically if we were
biology immortal it's very difficult to
to develop and grow and become something
new and evolve true so you know we have
kids the strong survive yeah we pass on
and the old genes go away and the new
ones carry on constantly changing and
finding a better way to move about so
right yeah we do need to you think this
is just an amusement park for people
like at the 4th dimension like oh I want
to go to spirit experience or work
dimension or we're the NPC's in there
and they're fantasy or yeah in one there
might just be one have you ever seen him
or the NPC and I'm the player there's a
movie with Ryan Reynolds called I think
it's called like the nines ever hear of
it no no no nines or something okay
basically this woman who I think it's
who's that was a McCarthy woman you know
that lady the fat lady from ghostbusters
yeah I think she's it I could be wrong
can you google this it's called like the
nines but she's basically warned to stay
away from this guy or something okay
because he's a nine and she's a three or
whatever and what that really means is
on a scale of like one to nine or
whatever about level of conscious
awareness and like you know beings okay
a three is like to us you know
character in you know Grand Theft Auto
walking around minding their own
business
mmm PC exactly yeah so he's a nine he
created this universe to her she views
him as a god but to put to put to Ryan
Reynolds and all of his peers they're
regular people and she's not like it's
you know but basically the plot is
basically at him going in a virtual
reality it but it's from an inverted
perspective interesting okay yeah did
you find it there's a lot of detail it's
broken into three chapters it's all
about three different dudes it's an
auction site with Ryan Reynolds yeah
yeah basically there's different
versions of reality okay and at the end
they like merge or something okay but
it's basically the general idea is he's
a higher form of life and to him these
are just realities he's created yeah as
a plaything
it's I want to give away the whole movie
but what it made sixty three thousand
dollars in the box office
yes sixty three I'm not saying it was a
good movie I'm saying it's an
interesting concept you know yeah I like
the idea but I don't know you know I'll
tell you this do you think it was worth
ten bird birds of prey I thought I
thought I thought the idea was
interesting I liked it Birds approach
but you know but but I will I will I
will add I don't know what happens when
we die I'm not worried about it though
I've never been scared and I'm you know
so when I've gone out to like conflict
reporting in dangerous places yep I've
you know I'll be scared I'm gonna get
hurt right but I'm literally never like
you know there have been times in my
life where I've just like been out in a
dangerous place and I've laughed I'm
like so this is it huh I think here we
go
yeah in Chicago got shot at and I was
running to dive behind this dumpster
this is how it happens and I saw I I
heard the bullet go past my face and I
saw the hole appear in front of me whoa
at in the dump at Chicago everybody I if
I was a foot to the right I would have
been dead wrists right now yeah that's
what I was like for me in Ferguson is
like whoa I was in Ferguson and I shots
went off hmm I dove to the ground and I
heard a whip crack yeah and it went
right in front of me but I just I I
literally belly dived yeah and just like
dragged my skin just like flop in the
ground and got down covered and I heard
it
my head and you know and there's
actually that wasn't even though that
was the first time there's footage of me
if you go look at the highlights we're
just we're just talking about it
and you can hear that pop and the cops
like run run and I'm like I'm freaking
out and then there's like a cut you
can't tell I passed I almost I basically
passed out from translation oh so I was
walking that was actually scary though
that was crazy so the tear gas displaced
oxygen in my lungs and I couldn't I
couldn't inhale or exhale and I started
getting tunnel vision as I was you know
hypoxic yeah and then I'm just like I
was in fallen panic mode I'm like I
can't breathe and then I just fell down
in the grass and then I wake up because
some kid walked out and poured a bottle
of water in my face has I had a gag
reflex yeah and then it pulled me out of
it nice and I was like I felt like I was
a guardian angel man because I was like
how did that kid come find me
yeah how did he know to pour water on me
to trigger a breathing reflex right
maybe he just thought he was tear-gassed
I better wash the gas off I don't know I
was on the ground and he just poured
water on my face in it woke me right up
cool dude any yeah it was a little it
was like a 15 year old kid or something
you and then he's like here man you need
this on mic - thank you it was crazy if
that's cool I really did I swear I had a
feeling like it felt like somebody was
watching over when that happened cuz I
don't know what I don't know if I was
gonna die or anything yeah but I
seriously was like in extreme panic
because I'm seeing the tunnels my vision
is closing mm-hm and you can hear me on
the camera I'm gasping like I can't
breathe
and there's like and that's it and then
I'm down and then and then it jump cuts
because they cut out the part I don't
know what happened the next scene is me
like filming myself yeah yeah dude
however that dude appeared there you
know with the bottle of water and splash
it on me felt like it was the fourth
dimensional player it felt like no it's
like you know somebody was like hey can
you come my dudes down I need to I need
a rez and then his body right now held
square down and then picked me up and
I'm like you know yeah no but in the
video games you're not like really like
so I'm like destiny for instance like
when you die air quotes your ghost is
chilling and then someone can come and
then resurrect you so you're not really
dead kind of but there's also you're in
the very in the first destiny when you
first wake up you've been dead for like
right a thousand years or something yeah
and they're like oh wow we found a
guardian like what are you doing out
here like resurrect you it's like oh
great but there are games too where it's
like when you go down you're just like
unconscious they come and inject you and
you're unconscious
yeah it was like that yeah thanks for
checking out this segment from the Tim
cast IRL podcast we do the show every
Monday through Friday at 8 p.m.
sometimes an hour or two and we do have
a full live recorded version of the show
that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts everyday after the show we make
them available in the community section
of this YouTube channel so don't forget
to subscribe and stick around for more
segments and more shows Monday through
Friday at 8 p.m.
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all in the next show
you